こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんペットは飼っていますでしょうか
僕も幼い頃はペットを飼っていました
僕はドジョウとうなぎとコーカサスオオカブトを飼ったことがあります
いやー皆いい子でした
で、僕思ったんですけども
ペットは飼い主さんがいないときいつも何をしてるのかと思いまして
ペットの動きとか行動とかをちょっと検証していきたいと思っております
というわけで今回の検証に協力してくださるペットのワンちゃんが２匹います
バリンちゃんとグレースちゃんでーす
おいでー
おー来てくれたー
よしよしよし
こちらがバリンちゃんで
こちらがグレースちゃんです
今回バリンちゃんとグレースちゃんと
ペットは飼い主がいない時一体彼らは裏でどのような行動をとっているのか
ひょっとしたらなんかこう飼い主がいない場所で何か特別なことをしているのかもしれません
というのを僕は気になったので今回検証して
この部屋じゃない所に僕はいて
この子たちの動きを観察していきたいと思います
ではいこう
はいというわけでまず３つ程色々やってみようと思うんですけども
まずは飼い主がいない状態
人がいない状態でペットはどんな行動をとっているのか
ちょっとシンプルにまずは検証していきましょう
こんな見つめられてもね（笑）
扉を見ているのかな？
多分僕が出てった扉をずっと見てます
結構ボーッとしてるんすね
あ、座っちゃった
あ、寝ちゃったのかな？
バリンちゃん完全に多分寝てます
バリンちゃんはわかるんですけど
今のカメラの位置だと
グレースちゃんがどこにいるかわかりませんので
カメラ位置を変えてきます
グレースちゃんがこれで見れるようになりました
今ソファの家で”俺がこの家の主だ”と言わんばかりに立っております
コミュニケーションとか取らないのかな？
あ、これグレースちゃん完全に寝ましたな
寝てますなｗ
はいご覧のとおりバリンちゃんは
扉をじっと見つめ
グレースちゃんは
ソファの上でゴロンと
今日もワンちゃん達は平和な１日を送っております
はいというわけで飼い主がいない時ペットは
寝ています
部屋を”オラァッ”って暴れまわったりすると思ってたんですけど
ちょっと想像と違いましたね
で、次なんですけども
この飼い主がいない部屋の中で
もし突然不審な人物が部屋の中に突然入ってきたら
ペット達はどういう反応をするのか
ちょっと検証してみようと思います
多分なんですけども飼い主とペットは固い絆で結ばれているので
もしね怪しい不審者が来たらちゃんと彼らは家を守る気持ちで不審な人物を追い払ってくれると思うので
では実際に不審者として突入してみましょう
はいというわけで不審者の格好ができました
僕は今からこの格好で
飼い主がいない部屋に入り込んで家の物の何かを盗んでいきます
それに彼らは反応できるかどうかか
今回のポイントです
それでは検証スタート
行ってきます
え？あれ怒ってました？
とりあえず吠えられたのでやばい人が来たなと思って守ったんだと思います
で、次のなんですけども
もし飼い主がいない部屋の中で
もう一匹特別な犬も準備したので
その子を友達として今からこの部屋に入れていこうと思います
果たしてバリンちゃんとグレースちゃんはどんな反応するのか
見てみましょう
最近勘違いしてる人が多いようなのですが
この字幕を打ってるのははじめしゃちょーではなく視聴者が打っております
大抵の字幕がある動画は視聴者が打っております
概要欄の下に誰が打ったかなど記載されております
その辺どうかご理解お願いします　この場をもって言わせてもらいました
はいというわけでいかがでしたでしょうか
ペットと飼い主の固い絆が見れた検証だったと思います
君達いい子だねホントに～
実は飼い主が留守にしている間ペット達はどんな行動をとっているのでしょうか
ペットを飼ったことがある人なら誰もが一度は考えたことがある
ペット達の裏側の日常と
飼い主の絆を描いた映画でございます
映画”ペット”が８月１１日の木曜日祝日に公開されます
僕実際に映画全部見たんですけども
ペットの裏の日常というかずっと笑ってられる楽しい映画になっております
ペットを飼った人も飼ったことがない人も皆楽しめる映画となっております
是非皆さん見に行ってください
じゃあな
完